[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
how do you know it's the best because we
simply said so it's friday and as you
all know summer fridays are the best day
on this show why because it is always
summer in miami this is a show that my
brothers and i wish that we had when we
were learning about business investing
in finance i have two of my brothers
here with me joe and john how do you
know their names are joe and john the
bazooka boys
are you guys are the bazooka boys now
union boys bazooka boys whatever y'all
want to call them yeah well the union
boys got beat by the island boys
got real quiet in here when i bring that
up that was still the death of the union
we're gonna get you don't worry yeah hey
i'm just saying listen boys their stock
is rising i wouldn't mess with anyone
called the bazooka boy
that's for sure that's dangerous
that is very dangerous i ain't gonna be
messing with youtube clowns uh all right
we got a whole bunch of stuff to go over
today
including we've got tons and tons and
tons of physical products that we're
giving out john has gone he's selected i
don't know what he's selected yet
hopefully i'm not going to be upset
about it but we're going to find out
here in a little bit so you know how the
game is played content's free all we ask
is you come in you hit the like button
when you hit the like button more people
on youtube see this more people that see
it more people get educated more people
get educated the better the world the
place uh the better a place the world is
which means that quite literally if you
press the like button the world becomes
a better place
so what we are going to do today is when
we hit 500 likes we're gonna start
giving away stuff one two three smash
the like button let's start getting
there
the second thing that we have going on
is sofi sofi.com pump now i have
gotten some details joe and john don't
even know these details yet
maybe you should share them with us yeah
i'm giving fair warning this is fair
warning sofi.com
we usually talk about their investment
accounts where you can go you can buy
stocks pre-ipo stocks you can buy
bitcoin etc but they also have a credit
card
and what i have been told is that when
we do our black friday cyber monday sale
if you use a sofi credit card
they will give you rewards points
equivalent to fifty dollars which will
negate any fifty dollars that you spend
in the store
so if you go in
and you buy let's say a t-shirt that
t-shirt's under 50
and you get the 50 reward it basically
negates it you actually make a little
money in some crazy way so
i'm not telling you that it might be a
good idea to have a sofi credit card but
i'm telling you it might be a good idea
to have a sofa credit card it'd be great
free merch it
it's technically not free
but you get paid back via rewards that
have a dollar value so what they're
gonna do is anyone who buys in the store
with the sofi credit card on those days
they're gonna give them these rewards so
that was very kind of them very nice of
them they told me yesterday i had asked
three times are you sure you want to do
that and they said yes so i'm excited
about it so go to software.com make sure
you read the terms and conditions there
and go get that credit card so you have
it ready the other thing that what i was
just doing fourth quarter i thought
that's what we were doing this quarter
what is going on today what are you
doing in court
taking over fourth quarter what you know
you're still in the third quarter
john in the fourth quarter reporting
earnings soon
are you guys good today yep union boys
are good bazooka boys are good island
boys are good all right fourth quarter
boys are good all right we got it we got
it we got it
next thing
is
it's friday and on friday we got to
start the show off with a nice
nice nice nice little energy shock to
the system
so
let's let's hit it let's get a little
mufasa
[Applause]
come on show us john here we go john
you're getting ready you're going around
the face oh spin move oh oh oh john
knows here it comes
no no here's the move this is john's
room coming right here here we go bounce
with me john bounce with me come on john
john hit me in the club with the bounce
ball
we can literally do that come on
give us a little little face there you
go yeah what do you got
send it back johnny set it back
you guys are full absolute fools
summer hey summer friday everybody knows
gotta be a good mood on a friday that's
how life works so make sure you guys
keep smashing the like button when we
cross over 500 likes john what is the
first item we're going to give away by
the way
um an irobot to clean your house
clean your house hands-free let's just
spit out my water did you see his face
those things work yeah they're sick look
at this thing get out of here
that's the thing that like cleans your
house without you doing anything exactly
the only time to be stacking sats do
whatever you want to do yeah so yeah so
you can basically stack sats and have a
clean house
[Laughter]
i don't know how you thought
it's right this is what we should give
away but uh we just crossed 500 likes
let's just do it right now ready on
count of three one two three drop your
twitter account or your instagram
account into the chat and we're gonna
pick one person john is obviously gonna
be the one picking winners today
and john is gonna pay his awesome what
are you talking about
somebody's getting a night robot we
shipped an air fryer to japan my house
dirty as hell
he said pick me please
if you get this we don't we only not
only need a photo but we definitely need
a video of this thing going around your
house have you got pets and they're
scared of it or something we need that
john the count of one or on a scale of
one to ten how satisfied are you with
this pick
eight point eight eight point eight
that's pretty that's pretty high you
could do better but definitely could do
worse
all right who we got as a winner for the
irobot before we get to some topics
jaden craig
j e j a i j a i d a n craig
congratulations you getting an irobot
clean your house you
win an i robot never thought you'd be
typing that out yeah hey i robot let's
go we're gonna uh keep you gotta you got
a different uh thing for the next one
don't tell us yet oh yeah all right so
listen keep smashing the like button
because i legitimately don't just random
products yeah i don't know what products
john picked but we're going to uh to
find out all right
yesterday i tweeted out a whole bunch of
questions and some of the information i
learned about the early days of bitcoin
even i didn't know i found very very
interesting and so today what we're
going to do is we're going to start off
by going through a couple of early days
of bitcoin of things that you may not
know
most people know that at october 31st
2008 halloween 2008 satoshi nakamoto
published the bitcoin white paper it's a
date that everyone knows on january 3rd
2009 the bitcoin blockchain was publicly
released most people know that date as
well but what you may not know is first
starting that the first block is block
zero it's not block one block zero
genesis block most of you probably do
know that you also know this message
here the times zero three jan 2009
chancellor and brink of second bailout
for banks so
that is all pretty much well-known
knowledge now let's go into the second
tweet that we have here i did not know
this
the first thing is that the genesis
block had 50 bitcoin in it obviously and
satoshi mined those 50 bitcoin but of
the 50 bitcoin from the genesis block
they technically are not spendable so
this is not something where so she went
and mined the 50 bitcoin and they could
turn around and have sold it to somebody
or even later once there was actual
liquidity exchanges infrastructure a us
dollar price assigned to it etc those 50
bitcoin and the genesis block are not
spendable so that was the first thing
that i think uh some people know that
but some people do not so some people
may find that interesting the second
thing was that the genesis block was
mined again block zero on january 3rd
2009 the first one but block one which
was technically the second block in this
in the blockchain wasn't mined until
january 8 2009. so after the first block
that second block when it was actually
mined was five days later so it didn't
just come out and immediately have every
10 minutes or so of block after block
being mined so five days later was the
genesis block now if we go ahead and we
look why is january 8th interesting on
january 8 2009 that lines up with an
email that was sent from satoshi to the
cryptography email list on the same date
and the nakamoto institute has all of
the emails that are uh you can just go
to
satoshi.nakamotoinstitute.org you see
all the emails there this specific email
talks about announcing the first release
of bitcoin a new electronic cash system
that uses a peer-to-peer network to
prevent double spending obviously
bitcoin one of the big technical
innovations was preventing double
spending it's completely decentralized
with no server or central authority
pretty clear-cut concise two-sentence
description of what bitcoin is and then
you can obviously there's a link to
download it it is only windows for now
wasn't available anything else just
windows open source c plus plus code is
included and then there's some
instructions on how you can actually
start to use the blockchain so that
alone is interesting the first block 50
bitcoin and the genesis block not
spendable from a technical standpoint
the second thing is that the second
block block one was not actually mined
until five days later on january 8 2009
at the same time there was the email to
the cryptography list and the release of
the uh public client for for bitcoin
then lastly we have jamison lop showed
me yesterday that satoshi not only
didn't pre-mine bitcoin but
it uh that person or group didn't even
fast mine bitcoin but it actually
throttled down the miners now patoshi
and satoshi are not necessarily the same
person but patoshi is known as a person
or a group that mined a ton of bitcoin
it's estimated around 700 000 bitcoin in
the first year and so what i found
interesting about this thing that
jameson pointed out is that
you can see in the data through those
block timestamp deltas that there was a
intentional throttling of the hash rate
so potoshi almost never mind blocks less
than five minutes apart this pattern was
revealed by sergio lerner in a recent
article at the time it was uh recent
about a year or two ago uh and then
jamison went and he actually verified it
himself and so what i think i
really kind of take away from a couple
of these details here is one is that
there is an immense constraint in mining
that much bitcoin never spending it
never touching it never doing anything
right kind of an altruistic uh view of
the world and the launch of this uh
product
two is that there was a very very
intentional uh and powerful foresight to
understand what some of the critiques in
the future could be and also an
understanding of what a truly fair
democratic uh kind of powerful launch of
this asset would be and so
i think that what i'm going to start
doing is on a couple of these shows i'm
going to go and i'm going to find
tidbits from the early days of bitcoin
i'm going to bring them up we're going
to talk about some of the things that if
you've been in bitcoin for a really
really long time if you were around
especially uh you know 2009 10 11 12 13
14 then you may know some of the stuff
that was kind of newer information but
there's a whole new class of people who
are showing up in 2017 18 19 20 21 and
they may not know some of these details
so we're gonna go find a bunch of them
for you and we're gonna keep bringing
them up and going through it i think we
may even at some point go through some
of the early satoshi emails and really
just walk through like here was the
conversation that was happening in the
early days that people can wrap their
heads around it so first block genesis
block 50 bitcoin not spendable second
block wasn't mined until january 8 2009
and then on january 8 2009 you also got
this email to the cryptography mailing
list saying hey announcing the first
release of bitcoin new electronic cash
system that uses peer-to-peer network to
prevent double spending download link
windows only and a bunch of instructions
on how to install it what did you guys
take away when you saw some of this
information
i thought it was interesting it's always
good to look at critiques or things that
people could eventually say or problems
with the system or the infrastructure
kind of the origin of bitcoin uh and go
back and like learn history about it so
i think it was cool uh i think it was
cool that people came out and gave their
research and their opinion and stuff
like that uh but yeah i think we should
continue to do and and seek out not only
the history of it but the other side of
the argument about what people could
eventually complain about
john it's a new asset right it's over
just a little bit over a decade old
people are still learning about what's
going on today and the innovations in
the future but they're also obviously
still learning about what has happened
in the past and kind of how bitcoin got
started this isn't really concerning to
me in any sense it's interesting to me
um i did not know this but it's nice to
see that people are still going back and
learning about it um look it's a new
asset people are going to continuously
talk about it and dig deeper and deeper
into the origins of bitcoin i would say
that we should have satoshi on the show
uh but we might have already
adam backed actually he was uh he was
doing a bunch of stuff and what i found
interesting uh is that um there's an
entire group of folks who were obviously
around uh in the very early days of
bitcoin and they there's a bunch of
blogs and a bunch of uh information that
they put out but most of this stuff was
written or they created the blogs and
the websites well before uh twitter
really became super popular for uh for
bitcoin um or before things like sub
stack etc podcasts weren't really big
right so so the uh mediums are a little
bit different so i think that kind of
going deeper and deeper down the rabbit
hole trying to find uh a lot of this
information there was a bunch of links
yesterday that were super helpful so i
appreciate everyone um you know sending
those in but i i do think that there is
a uh
a really powerful uh thing of studying
the past to understand the present and
when you start to look at how the launch
went or the creation right um marty bent
calls it like the immaculate conception
of bitcoin it's really special right i
mean there's nothing else that we've
seen that can do that and uh stacy um
from the orangeville podcast uh she had
a great point she said that uh
essentially there's an observer effect
right the first three or four years of
bitcoin's existence
very small group of people really cared
we're paying attention we're watching
this we're participating in it uh and so
it was able to almost kind of grow you
know if you think of almost like a baby
right and it kind of grows and grows and
grows until all of a sudden now it's
this big resilient decentralized thing
that um could kind of handle uh much
much more um uh scrutiny then all of a
sudden it was there by the time people
started paying attention today nothing's
getting launched without you know
immediately being critiqued looked at et
cetera because just too many people are
paying attention so yeah
it's what it was just different times
yeah of course well and it was a true
zero to one innovation right i think
that's the other piece that everyone
forgets is like i always go back to uh
bitcoin did not just like fall out of
the sky from a computer science
standpoint you know there's 40 plus
years of work that went into the
eventual creation of bitcoin everything
going all the way back to literally the
creation of tci tcpip to a bunch of
cryptography uh you can go back and you
can look at the creation of proof of
work you can look at uh many other
digital currency attempts like um you
know uh digi cash and a bunch of those
way they had a couple of them et cetera
um and when you start to look at the
totality of this it's not just a
technical revolution that was going on
or technical uh innovations that were
happening there was also uh kind of a um
a social component or like a an ethos
component as well right so you can go
back and you can look at a lot of the
cypherpunk work that happened beforehand
you can look at uh things like the
manifestos that were written uh and you
can start to just see like okay now in
hindsight you can see the 40 plus year
lead up to the creation of bitcoin but a
bitcoin still had this immaculate
conception type idea gets launched bam
there we go now it's a one 1.2 plus
trillion dollar asset and uh it's ready
to rock and roll right
what do you guys read
agreed agreed
right
i'm laughing at the it's ready to rock
and roll part at the end there but it
it's right it goes so yeah it's matured
over the last decade bitcoin itself but
obviously technology has led up to the
creation of bitcoin and will probably in
the future as well innovation gets built
on innovation
com completely agree uh all right we've
got one other thing real quick i just
saw this meme on the internet i thought
this was a good one so we're gonna pull
it up just so you guys like it
me new drop of the best business show
don't mind it we do
it's pretty good right
if you send us memes we will be forced
to pull them up if they're good memes
sorry not sorry this is a a a random
fact here but i saw this the other day
and i don't know if it's true i saw a
thing that said leonardo dicaprio hasn't
dated a woman over 25 years old in in
his entire life what that's wild if
that's when your 25th birthday is coming
up you're shaking
you're like damn i'm out of leo's video
like i read some
how old is he he's wait what
yeah he's fine we're not gonna spend the
show talking about leonardo dicaprio uh
and his uh um
and all his nonsense yes also
uh junior dude cocktail i think is how
you pronounce your name uh less than 250
blocks left until taproot upgrade which
uh which is pretty cool so we're we're
closing in here on uh the taproot
upgrade on monday or sunday
well 250 blocks so it depends on how
quickly the blocks uh come in but uh
john loves the tap root button
we're talking about that monday yeah
we're gonna talk about on monday topic
number one topic number one topic number
one you picked the topics we'll uh we'll
do a whole little deep dive on it all
right we're getting close ready one two
three go smash the like button if you
smash the like button or give away
what's the next product we're giving
away here john all right next on the
list is uh
a digital picture frame
all right
a digital picture frame nice nice nice
what is how does it work you load up
pictures and then they can cycle through
pictures so it's not so you can put like
uh you put whatever you want pictures of
your family picture of a bitcoin picture
of your dog a picture of a bitcoin your
wallet address just flashing
all right actually you know what i think
this is a great gift for is if you get
this right now you could turn around and
they have to buy one less christmas gift
i was just going to save this yeah
pomp boys specials
this is like a re-gift special you get
this you're like oh my god amazing thank
you guys so much the best business show
is amazing whoop mom guess what
we we're basically buying someone's mom
a christmas gift right here that's how
this is going to work
count of three one two three drop your
twitter account drop your instagram
account when we come back uh from the
next topic then joe will have picked a
winner basically getting somebody
somebody's uh mom's
gift for christmas
or for them or if you want to keep it
that's fine hey no i would keep it
personally but no problem
all right
grayscale has reached over 60 billion
dollars in aum grayscale for years has
served as the number one way for
institutions that cannot directly buy
bitcoin to go into a publicly traded
fund they have a trust that people can
go ahead and they can allocate to what
we are now seeing is that grayscale has
expanded past just one fund they now
have 12 total but 97
of their assets are concentrated in two
of the funds and 72 percent are in the
bitcoin trust in the gbtc product
michael schunenstein who i've had on the
podcast multiple times has
told i think cnbc or cnn i'm not sure
which one uh the gbtc holds greater than
three percent of all bitcoins in
circulation so this is a massive massive
position that they have we've got their
kind of asset breakdown across products
here if you look at that grayscale
bitcoin trust gbtc this is a aum of 43.5
billion dollars 43.5
billion dollars is a bonkers number and
so when you go ahead and you look at
just how much bitcoin is in that gbtc uh
vehicle people will forget one thing
which is that if we go back to october
november and december of 2020 last year
what a lot of folks on wall street were
doing is they were coming into the
market and that gbtc product had a
premium it was trading sometimes 10 15
sometimes even 20 premium to the actual
nav the assets that were in the vehicle
and so what a bunch of wall street folks
would do is they would go to the private
uh placement of grace kill they would
give them money and they would say hey i
want to buy shares in your fund
grayscale would create the shares those
shares would be held by the investor for
six months in one day it was illiquid
you were not from a regulatory
standpoint allowed to sell them for six
months in one day after six months in
one day you could then sell the shares
in the public market you were selling
them at a premium so equivalent would be
if you contributed one bitcoin or the
dollar amount equivalent to one bitcoin
you got a share you held it and then all
of a sudden six months and one day later
you could sell it for basically one
bitcoin plus 20
right if there's a 20 premium so this
was a premium arbitrage opportunity but
the impact that it had on the market was
really important because all of these
institutions were coming in they were
giving greyscale money and when they
were giving greyscale money grayscale
was creating their private shares there
is no redemption function on the gbtc
product meaning that grayscale does not
have the ability for you to give them
shares and they give you back the
bitcoin that is in the fund so once the
bitcoin goes in the fund it doesn't come
back out it essentially is the ultimate
strong hand because the fund does not
allow for redemptions and so as all
these people were piling into the
grayscale arbitrage trade really what
was happening was grayscale was taking
that money and they were going into the
market they were buying bitcoin at one
point grayscale was literally buying
more than 100 of the bitcoin that was
being mined in any given day and so they
were just constantly taking supply out
of the market making a super uh already
illiquid asset even more and more
illiquid of course bitcoin's price
absolutely ran up it went from about 10
12 000 in october early november all the
way up to eventually hit 64 000 in march
of 2021 and so when you start to see
just how much bitcoin is in this thing
it's pretty crazy now one of the things
that we are watching we've been talking
about is that grayscale with that gbtc
product that trust has already indicated
that they would like to convert it from
a trust into a spot etf if they convert
it into a spot etf one the premium or
discount there's a discount now would go
away it would trade much closer to nav
which ultimately i i personally think
would be much better for investors the
second thing is that there would also be
a redemption functionality and so there
would be less of an illiquid supply
being uh contributed to by that gbtc
product and so it remains to be seen
what the timeline is for converting gbtc
and that trust product into a spot etf
because the sec has not yet approved any
spot etfs but i think there's a light at
the end of the tunnel because the sec
has obviously already gone ahead and
approved a bitcoin futures etf now we've
got this quote from michael shonenstein
that says when we do see that approval
because it will be a when not an if we
do think it would draw more investors
and more capital into the ecosystem so
we're watching this very closely we tend
to think that uh eventually it will
actually get um converted it's just
going to take some time so what do we
think about uh gbtc uh you know 40 plus
billion dollars just in that uh gbtc
product being held from like an illiquid
standpoint it's amazing as the price
rises obviously the aum will rise as
well i was really interested in the fact
that he said that they hold three
percent of all the bitcoin that's a
massive number in my opinion but we'll
see and then the etf stuff look
he's they're not waiting on they're
waiting on the sec to approve this etf
and i feel like once they do they're
gonna go pedal the metal uh full gas and
try to get this converted as soon as
possible yeah it's interesting uh the
three percent too i don't even know if
that it doesn't sound like that includes
uh you know the coins that they the
bitcoins that they've have expected that
are lost or will not be retrieved or
moved ever so they obviously hold a lot
of the supply of bitcoin currently and
it's a massive fund it gives people
exposure that couldn't get in other ways
right like i we've talked about this
before i own some gbtc in my retirement
account
but the problem is right it's just been
super volatile from a premium and a
discount perspective it'll be
interesting to see what happens with the
etf obviously they'll have a huge huge
huge structural advantage uh if it comes
to converting it to a spot etf just from
an aunt perspective but we always talk
about incentives drive everything and
their incentives point to them uh
actually not converting it right they'll
earn higher fees on the current
structure versus an etf maybe they'll
see more inflows uh given now that it
trades at a discount and they're not
getting those flows that they were
seeing previously uh but it'll be
interesting to see if they're one of the
first people to convert if they're one
of the uh the later people to convert if
they do convert if they don't convert et
cetera i think that story is far from
over
the other piece in the
institutional adoption is that we now
are seeing some of the institutions be
able to actually buy the assets
themselves i do not think that they
could have just blindly bought assets uh
in the past um in terms of uh i go into
the market and i buy the asset i put it
on my balance sheet i hold it and that
meets my investment mandate right
there's all kinds of uh risk controls
etc i think that there was one big step
which was that micro strategy and
michael sailor went ahead and bought
bitcoin and put it on their balance
sheet so you had a publicly traded
company say this is an investment grade
asset we have the ability to get in and
if we wanted to there is the liquidity
to get out right from a risk management
standpoint and also there's a way for us
to custody this that meets our custody
requirements from being a regulated sec
registered business and so when you saw
that that was kind of step one we have
some more publicly traded companies
doing that then the second thing is we
now have a public pension that's
actually bought the bitcoin directly and
put on their balance sheet the houston
firefighters department and so i think
that uh when you start to see some of
these institutions doing it you always
need one to get to two but once you get
one two then eventually it becomes many
and i think that's what we're watching
happening here is that the funds were
the only way previously to be able to do
this now what we're starting to see is
that uh they can go ahead and they can
buy direct and so you're opening up the
opportunity for more and more
institutions to come in the market and
have choice as to how they want to
actually allocate to the asset based on
what their risk parameters are what
their compliance departments and what
their regulatory regime uh allows them
to do right i think everyone understands
like hey they would like to buy the
bitcoin and hold the private keys uh but
depending on what that uh kind of
structure is they may or may not be
allowed to do that personally i think
there's a lot of companies that are
looking at bitcoin but they can't
because of the risk structure and the
compliance and the volatility of it but
if you think of it on a long-term asset
what's it saying when in doubt zoom out
right when you think about and the
amount that it's appreciated over the
last decade it makes it a no-brainer to
at least put a little bit of exposure on
your balance sheet michael seller has
gone to the almost extreme of putting
114 000 bitcoin on their balance sheet
the
yes but i think that the key is that
he's not only bought it but he he's uh
custodying it himself right that the
custody component to me is really
important and when i say custodying it
himself uh he's using a external
third-party custody solution so he's not
michael saylor's not walking around with
private keys in his pocket yeah yeah
yeah but but uh they're not getting the
exposure via a fund right it would be a
very different story i think uh if a
publicly traded company whether it was
microstrategy or anybody else said hey
we want to get bitcoin exposure we're
going to go buy a
futures based etf a spot etf or even
we're going to go buy uh the publicly
traded trust that's a little bit of a
different story than like we're buying
the bitcoin uh itself and then we're
having some sort of custody solution
provided what i do wonder is it when the
banks start to actually custody right
we've seen the occ director uh come out
and basically say hey look we're looking
at how to allow banks to custody these
assets uh if they
if banks are allowed to do that how many
more of these institutions whether their
banks their uh pension funds foundations
whatever start to uh enter into bitcoin
because now they they're trusted bank
right and i'll put that in their quotes
because you know
trust that your own apparel yeah but uh
how many of them now will do it because
all of a sudden the banking partner
they've had for 20 30 40 years right
will allow them to actually custody
those assets there yeah i think it's
huge because uh when you think about
bitcoin specifically everyone that wants
to own it usually wants to own uh the
physical asset right they want to own
bitcoin itself and they want to
custodiate themselves similar to what
michael saylor has done the trust
usually in my mind is used as a
structure uh one is a wrapper right if
you want to buy that structure but also
it's used in situations where you're not
able to actually buy bitcoin right and
retirement accounts are the perfect
example of that because there's certain
instances where you cannot uh purchase
bitcoin directly in a retirement account
depending on kind of what it is or what
vehicle it is so gbtc specifically when
it comes to bitcoin gives you that
exposure uh it doesn't correlate
one-to-one right like it directionally
yes but one-to-one no but it gives you
enough exposure to it where you're still
getting some of that kind of return that
the asset might provide uh but just in a
different structure
john
we got a winner
yeah who's the winner uh cloudstrife543
cloud
cloud strife 543. congratulations you've
got yourself a digital picture frame
amazing john did you get me on twitter
you're such a good guy such a good guy
trying to help out it's coming up the
best season the holiday season
all right yesterday was big news that we
had uh in terms of the miami mayor
announced that he was going to pay
all of the citizens of miami bitcoin so
what this looks like is that a
miami resident would be allowed to go in
and get a digital wallet get paid
bitcoin by the city now there was tons
and tons of questions all kinds of
people saying hey this is amazing hey i
have questions how does it work why how
is the uh yield generated what is a
bitcoin dividend etc so we are going to
bring uh two people on the show today
that are going to help us answer these
questions we've got both uh patrick
stanley and munib from stacks coming on
and they're going to help us explain
smart contracts on bitcoin pros cons
what are the risks what are the uh kind
of forward-looking um kind of things to
be excited about also two is we've got
patrick stanley uh from the city coins
project going to explain exactly how
this works how is uh miami getting the
bitcoin to be able to pay to folks and
then also why are places like new york
doing this before we get to them though
very quickly
there's a golden rule of retirement it's
called the four percent rule and
morningstar yesterday released the paper
saying that the four percent rule should
really be closer to three percent now
that sounds insane when we live in a
world where there is literally so much
asymmetry in things like bitcoin etc the
difference between three and four
percent doesn't sound like that big but
when you talk about a golden rule of
retirement that's where you can start to
see why these little changes are so
important so what is the four percent
rule the four percent rule you add up
all of your investments and you withdraw
four percent of that total during your
first year of retirement in subsequent
years you adjust the dollar amount you
withdraw to account for inflation so
four percent meaning that if i have a
hundred dollars in my retirement account
on year one i take out four percent
every year after that i essentially
adjust the four percent based on what
the inflation level is so why do people
go ahead and use the four percent rule
it's meant to yield a consistent stream
of annual income and give people a high
degree of comfort that their funds will
last over a 30-year retirement so you're
planning for 30 years of retirement and
what you're trying to do is stay
regimented on a disciplined plan of
exactly what is the total amount in my
retirement account and how much should i
be withdrawing on a year by year basis
now the new rule instead of four percent
morningstar is saying that it should be
more like 3.3 percent now something that
is so small so teeny in terms of a
difference is really important when it's
an actual number that is applied over a
30-year period somewhere like
compounding if you were to have one
percent compounding versus two at the
end of 30 years it's a really big
difference same thing here so if you're
withdrawing four percent or 3.3 big big
difference so here is the translation
for the everyday american you have to
have even more money in your retirement
account in order to be able to actually
make this work four percent let's say
you had a hundred dollars you were only
taking out four percent that'd been four
dollars now they're saying take out 3.3
so if you still only have 100 in your
retirement account you take out 3.3 that
means you're only trying to live now on
3 and 30 cents rather than the 4 before
it's a very very serious reduction in
the aggregate dollar amount of what
you're pulling on so you actually have
to increase the total amount that is in
your retirement account when you retire
so that if you're only taking out 3.3 it
ends up being the same or more on an
aggregate dollar amount that it used to
be
four percent rule may not work well in
coming decades due to lower projected
stock and bond returns you think we are
watching absolute historic inflation
bonds absolutely trash negative real
returns and so of course people are
gonna have to start changing the way
that they think about retirement when
you guys saw the four percent going down
to 3.3 does this matter at all or is
this just uh geniuses trying to be too
smart no i think it matters in the sense
of when you have that retirement but
look my retirement plan is to make a ton
of money and then have multiple streams
of passive income that you can live off
of so you're not living off those
savings for that 30 plus years right and
this is really only planning for 30
years of retirement if you want to
retire by the time you're 50 or 60 years
old and you live to be 100 years old
then yeah it becomes a big deal in the
long uh grand scheme of things but i
don't think it's a big deal on the one
percent or point seven percent basis
that they actually adjusted it on yeah
i mean uh it seems like a small number
in in aggregate it can make a big
difference i guess uh but i i kind of
agree with the latter stage of smart
people trying to be too smart
just saying multiple streams of passive
income that's a good retirement plan for
me mailbox money jack mailbox money
mailbox
that's the greatest term ever dominican
had the mailbox money quote the other
day because uh was it canelo uh canelo
said that he's invested so much money
into real estate that right now he makes
three to four million dollars a quarter
in passive income off the real estate
and the dominant zoo says that's that
mailbox money yeah that's it that's what
we call mailbox money
what did you take from that joe one no
they're talking about it it's just
passive income right like canelo we
don't know kind of the capital that he's
invested in it but receiving three to
four million dollars per quarter in
dividends from your real estate holdings
is obviously substantial uh and it's
what every athlete should really strive
for right he's made a bunch of money in
his career and now he's building up an
investment portfolio that continues to
pay him and people say you know there's
a bunch of different different
investments out there you can do venture
you can do stocks you can do bonds et
cetera crypto whatever it might be but
ultimately cash coming in is is pretty
good especially when uh you're a
professional athlete and your career
doesn't normally last as some others
might be right canelo's 32 years old or
something like that i believe right so
maybe he boxes for however many more
years longer but he's not going to be
boxing at 45 50 60 years old so having
money coming in each quarter especially
as those continue to grow right it's
three to four million now per quarter
maybe it's six seven eight nine ten
million later on in life uh it's a
substantial amount of money that he's
gonna continue to be able to live off of
a great thing you can do with that
mailbox money is actually stretch it or
stretch it across different industries
so he has what gas stations he's a boxer
right so he's not normally associated
with that but uh if you can build the
structure and like buy businesses mellow
energy canelo
gas stations are called is that right
that's what you said yeah that's awesome
trillionaire
we'll
energy
all right we've got uh munib and patrick
here with us we're gonna uh try to wrap
our heads here around what exactly is
going on how are you guys
good how are you i'm doing fantastic i
appreciate you guys both jumping on i
know that uh for for patrick elise it's
early over there so thank you um i know
it's all good maybe what we can start
with is moonee we'll start with you in
terms of uh stacks and smart contracts
on top of bitcoin i think the first
question that people have is just like
why is it important to bring this
functionality uh to bitcoin and then how
exactly does it technically work from an
architecture standpoint
yeah i think the way to think about this
is uh bitcoin is decentralized money uh
and it is it is amazing i think it's
just going to change the world and right
now if you look at the use case of
bitcoin people are mostly like either
buying and holding it or they're trading
bitcoin on centralized exchanges and the
next evolution of this is when you can
actually do really interesting things
with bitcoin in a completely
decentralized way imagine that you could
trade bitcoin or decentralize the
changes you could participate in lending
uh protocols where you're lending in a
completely trustless manner earning
interest on your bitcoin you can put up
your bitcoin as collateral and you can
start building all sorts of interesting
decentralized applications that are
using bitcoin as a settlement layer so i
think bitcoin as sound money is the
first step
deploying that bitcoin making it
productive deploying it into smart
contracts and decentralized uh finance
that's step number two and then the last
step is the use of bitcoin as a
settlement layer i think it's a global
settlement layer you want the world
trade to settle on bitcoin you want all
important information on the on the
planet to settle on bitcoin eventually
and the smart contracts for bitcoin are
a critical piece for enabling step two
and step three i think we're on step one
right now and and we really want to get
to step two and step three
got it and when you talk about the kind
of technical architecture uh explain how
this works because i think that uh when
people hear um smart contracts on
bitcoin i see a bunch of people debating
is it on bitcoin is it a side chain of
bitcoin is it whatever frankly i don't
know how much important is the
nomenclature as much as just like how
does it work
yes i think the simplest mental model
for this is uh you want the bitcoin base
layer to be very simple very durable you
don't want to change you don't want it
to be very complex right you can look at
some of the other
alternative blockchains out there like
ethereum and others and they decided to
make their base blockchain very complex
with smart contracts and that comes with
a bigger security attack vector so the
way bitcoin works is the base layer is
not going to change is very simple so
it's almost like a two-layered solution
so the base layer is bitcoins
decentralized money and then you add
some sort of a additional layer on top
that brings smart contracts and i think
that's where people get into all sorts
of different solutions is either side
chain is it is it like an l2 without
getting into the technical details what
stacks really does is that it tries to
enable
fully expressive smart contracts for
bitcoin meaning that anything you can
build on ethereum or anywhere else you
can build that in the bitcoin ecosystem
now and developers are re this is
something that is really resonating with
developers because they see the trillion
dollars in capital that is just sitting
there with bitcoin and they want to come
and build applications on top and can
you give us just some high level uh
stats on like how many people are
actually building in the ecosystem
yes so i think uh so what over the past
like six seven months or so so stacks
only went live this year uh we now have
i think 1
300 something smart contracts published
on the blockchain the 10x effectively in
the last three months or so and there
are organic things happening like you
know bitcoin nfts like i that caught me
by surprise there are something like
three or four organic marketplaces that
emerge for for nfts if people are
familiar with open c
uh and marketplaces like that on
ethereum so that's already happening in
bitcoin and and and there are so many
artists there are so many developers who
are coming in and basically launching
all sorts of different applications i
believe there are more than 30 startups
now in in the ecosystem and these
startups are building things like
stablecoins lending protocols like you
name it right like it said it's a really
like
exciting time to be around for the smart
contract space in bitcoin
got it and so uh patrick let's talk
about what's going on in miami first and
then we will talk about uh new york um
and maybe what i'll do is i'll play
devil's advocate i tried to get uh one
or two folks to come on that were asking
you a bunch of questions yesterday and
uh as one of them said to me kindly he
said hey man i got a job can we do this
at night and i was like well i can't
really move the show but uh so i think
i've got most of their questions in
terms of like what people are are
interested in uh the first is how is it
that the city of miami ends up with a
treasury and then also earning bitcoin
yield like how does that work from a a
technical standpoint or like an
architecture standpoint
yeah i'm happy to give the technical
overview um first thing i just want to
say is that
mayor suarez just turned his city into
like an oil
producing country that yields bitcoin
and i'll tell you how that happens
so
um when you mine
city coins like miami coin
30
of uh the cryptocurrency that you're
sending in to mine goes directly to the
city so you know when you mine bitcoin
you spend electricity when you mine city
coins you spend cryptocurrency that
crypto just happens to be stacks
which happens to yield approximately 10
apy in bitcoin and that's a nominal
yield so if the value of tax goes up the
yield goes up commensurate to that
so when you're sending in those stacks
30 to mine 30 goes directly to the
city's treasury that's why the city of
miami has almost 22 million dollars
worth of stacks after just three months
of this protocol going live now that
number is just going to go up and up and
up and up and up in terms of stats and
therefore the amount of uh bitcoin that
that treasury can yield will also uh go
go up as a function of uh the stacks
being added to the treasury um
ongoingly just being added so okay i
treasure yeah so once you get that
treasury there and they are generating
the bitcoin yield that is what uh mayor
suarez in miami is saying he is going to
take the bitcoin yield and he used a
very specific term of a dividend right
he's basically going to give that to the
citizens now my understanding and what
some of the questions we're around is we
don't have all the details right there
there isn't necessarily like hey here's
exactly how this is going to work but
the high level uh appears to be that any
citizen can come in they can get any
digital wallet doesn't matter what
company what brand you know whoever
built it uh custodial non-custodial the
whole nine yards
they then will get
some
future to be determined amount of that
bitcoin so the citizens are getting
bitcoin in a digital wallet that they
control it's not a city created um a
digital wallet like a chivo wall or
anything like that this is just off the
shelf from the market uh but it's a
dividend it's not the city going and
buying bitcoin in like the open market
and turning around like handing it to
citizens that's right so uh that's right
so you know cities
city the reason cities don't just bot
simply buy bitcoin is because taxpayers
would be so incredibly uh mad at them if
they did that because they're maybe um
maybe asking taxpayers for money out of
their own pockets to get bitcoin uh what
what suarez did with miami coin is he uh
added tax revenue he added non-tax
revenue to uh to the city that they can
distribute to to uh folks in terms of
bitcoin now um that's right and uh in
terms of like people using wallets i i
believe the city is looking for uh the
sort of best possible uh you know way to
do this in a uniform
you know kind of like sensible way so
like i don't have all the details um
they're gonna determine that but
one thing i think actually could be
really useful here is using lightning
channels and getting the city set up on
not just bitcoin but lightning and uh
ongoingly uh sort of metering out uh
bitcoin
and how would that work
um so
the city has to figure that out
essentially that's like they're talking
to folks from from lightning uh from
different lightning uh sort of companies
and essentially what would happen is uh
all the bitcoin that's yielding from the
um the city's tax treasury would go into
a wallet uh that would set up set up a
you know payment channels with all the
sort of citizens or maybe go into
multiple wallets and uh be sent
automatically you could also do it
without lightning but there's a lot of
citizens and i'm sure lightning would be
helpful
so for example uh and i'm just gonna use
one that i uh one i'm an investor in but
also two i understand intimately and
they've done a bunch of like payment
bitcoin type stuff is somebody could go
they could get a strike wallet and the
city could use the lightning network
take the bitcoin that they've earned as
part of that yield and then pay out to a
user who has that strike wallet uh and
that's the way that the city would
essentially be sending bitcoin to a you
know private citizen
yeah i can i can chime in on the go
ahead how does this can work so
basically think of this as uh let's
roughly call it at 20 million dollars
worth of treasury uh with a 10 yield
you're talking about two million dollars
worth of uh bitcoin projected but this
this might actually given given that the
donations these are kind of like
donations coming into the treasury so
donations might keep going up right so
it might be like a 50 million treasury
we don't know
we'll see how this turns out but the
yield is dependent on that so let's call
it anywhere between two to five million
dollars in bitcoin uh once you start
looking at it as bitcoin in satoshi's
that's actually a pretty large number
right so you're you're you're because a
single bitcoin has like 100 million
satoshis so you're talking about a large
number of stats that are available for
these citizens and you don't want to
lose a lot of them in transaction fees
right so the ideal way to do it is over
lightning like you help people set up
lightning channels imagine that the
entire city government would have to
understand lightning they would have to
build up their own lighting
channels which is super exciting the
amount of education the bitcoin
education that happens over here and
then the people who on board not
everyone's going to on board right so it
might seem like okay maybe five million
dollars worth of bitcoin isn't a lot a
it's a lot in stats b not everyone is
likely going to onboard only the people
who actually go through the learning
journey of what bitcoin is what lighting
is i i think this thing is valuable and
i want to get some for me the biggest
benefit here is the learning journey
when people they get their first
satoshi's like in their wallet they
experience a payments rail uh that is
fully decentralized that is a new type
of a sound money i think that's the
thing that that explains excites me the
most about
what's going on in miami
got it and then patrick talk to me about
new york it seems like obviously there's
this like uh competition going on now i
wrote this morning about we've got four
mayors across the united states that are
all getting uh a portion of their salary
paid in bitcoin we have cool valley
missouri uh jason stewart there he's
paying out um about a thousand dollars
of bitcoin to his citizens uh the city
of new york is now saying eric adams hey
we're going all in on this stuff like
how do we become a leader in this space
so what's going on in new york
yeah so uh eric adams is watching what
suarez is doing and he's seeing a new
model for a mayor
right so this is a mayor that makes out
group arguments to pull uh talent and
capital into their municipality which is
really smart most mayors don't even
realize that this is uh this is this is
uh
essentially a game that's going on right
now they're essentially most mayors are
like asleep at the wheel in terms of
like um uh how to be a mayor in the 21st
century in this regard and so eric adams
uh is refusing to just uh be like your
prototypical uh 20th century mayor and
he's looking to compete with with suarez
and so he saw miami coin he said he saw
he was doing well and he said he wanted
to
go in that direction so the community
decided to activate new york city coin
new york city coin now has two million
dollars in its treasury that is uh that
they can do it with whatever they want
that two million dollars can also be
stacked or in bitcoin they could
literally copy suarez and you know
become that oil producing country that
gives a dividend to their citizens um
but i think essentially you're gonna see
this like this decade you're gonna see
tons of mayors competing for talent and
capital just like a ceo of a company
would be and the reason being the reason
for that is that um
we are essentially living in like a
default remote first world for
information workers so people are
choosing cities like their choosing
products
and um
and and so you know
you know you moved from new i think new
york to miami um during the pandemic
you've never been happier
and you chose miami like a product and
you love miami so like um you know city
coins is great too just like as an
additional thing uh as just like another
way of voting sort of right so like you
used to be able to vote with your ballot
and uh with your feet you voted with
your feet to miami i don't watch your
vote on the ballot so i don't know if
you're voting but now you can vote with
your coin you can the market can signal
uh their approval or disapproval of um
of essentially how capital is spent and
how the leadership performs so if you
you mine or buy or build on city coins
you are committed to the city or sorry
sorry if you hold city coins you're
committed to the city if you mind buy or
build you are bullish on city leadership
if you sell certain city coins you're
bearish on city leadership so let me ask
this question when you guys think about
this the number one thing i saw people
asking was what are the risks right
obviously this stuff is brand new i
think that there's uh kind of two
different things that are uh going on
here that are working in tandem right
now you guys are two separate
organizations so maybe i'll miniv i'll
start with you and then patrick will
come to you it's just when you think
about the pros and the cons what do you
think is the most rational uh con
argument or the biggest risk that you're
like yeah you know what like we're aware
of it and we're trying to either
mitigate it or that's what people need
to be aware of as they look at these
systems
yeah i can
get started so i think the way to think
about this is for the longest time even
in the history of bitcoin uh you would
notice that the early bitcoin developers
they would call bitcoin an expert right
i think you know now it's almost been
more than a decade and i think it's
maturing a lot but if you look at the
the the stacks protocol think of stacks
as a programming layer for bitcoin
stacks itself is a decent large protocol
right there's no company behind it i
think there are 30 plus companies that
are contributing in various ways
building stuff but it is an open source
decentralized protocol but compared to
bitcoin is relatively new right it only
launched this year the technology hasn't
been kind of like
tested as heavily as bitcoin has been
tested and then some of the things that
people are building on top like the
community driven uh city coins project
that is another layer on top so i think
people should treat these things as like
very experimental very innovative very
exciting but experimental and and in
terms of the
the city the city is kind of like
getting a donation they could like write
it off like because the value of
cryptocurrencies can go up or down these
are very volatile things but i think at
this point like for for them it's a
donation right so the the donation value
might go down that's that's a risk uh if
they're if they're earning bitcoin uh
and the crypto markets kind of crash the
value of bitcoin goes down the value of
kind of like the treasury goes down that
that's at risk but i think the
interesting thing here is that they're
willing to engage right patrick just
mentioned uh some of the stats on on the
new york launch that the community just
did i i want to emphasize something here
the the two million dollars that he's
talking about is over the past 24 hours
maybe not even the past 24 hours there's
so much interest and i don't even know
like who these miners are like i'm not
i'm not mining but i saw that the so
there's a threshold of miners like a
minimum number of miners who can come in
and uh kind of like trigger the launch
that trigger was reached within three
minutes
within three minutes basically there
were there was enough mining power to
just trigger the launch of this thing
over the last 24 hours you already have
two million dollars in the in the
treasury that now the mayor has an
incentive like by the time i think the
the new york mayor actually takes office
like who knows how much capital as
donations is already sitting in the
treasury and the community is just doing
it i think so there's something powerful
in this concept of almost like
onboarding cities uh to web 3. like i
think we have seen cities onboard to web
2 when they made like the dot gov
websites and they started thinking about
how to offer city services on the
internet i think this is cities thinking
about how do they operate how how do
they communicate with their citizens and
offer new type of services by making use
of crypto protocols and i think it's a
very exciting new place where lots of
experimentation would actually be a good
thing
and then patrick what do you think about
in terms of risks or or the biggest
things that uh people have to think
about how they're underwriting it
i think we've squared this thing like
pretty pretty nicely um i think we need
miniv outlay uh sort of the risk this is
experimental um
experimental but i think the design is
pretty good honestly and
we're using we're using
we're using a smart contracting language
that uh
stacks an algorithm team sort of uh sort
of co-developed and worked on called
clarity just like you know if you were
writing like nuclear grade smart
contracts like you're dealing with a lot
a lot of money you'd use clarity um so
um
we we feel pretty good about it honestly
one thing one one thing about clarity is
uh it's not a tutoring complete language
which means that you can actually do
formal verifications you can actually
be much more secure about
what this program can and cannot do and
there's already a billion dollars locked
up in a smart contract written in
clarity right so at least there are
there has been other types of capital
that has been locked in in these smart
contracts and then if other people are
using it you know they can they can
learn from what what has already been
done
got it joe john what questions do you
guys have yeah so we we've seen uh
miami's obviously done this and they've
accepted it and all that in new york
we'll see what they end up doing
when when the new uh government
officials take over but my question is
how many cities can do this like in your
guys mind how quickly will this go how
many more cities will adopt this how
will this look in in 12 24 months
uh i think i think in two years there's
going to be over 100 um
city coin cities
so every startup city
is going to have a city point
every technologically progressive mayor
of a city where there's a lot of demand
from the community is going to have a
city point
and just so happens the two best mayors
of the biggest cities in the united
states uh have city coins and are
technologically progressive you know
david sacks uh david sachs actually had
a good tweet thread about this couple
days ago and he essentially he was like
quote tweeting uh eric adams's approval
of uh new york city coin and he said um
you know suarez essentially had 18
months uninterrupted of being able to uh
being able to just like clean up and you
know be the best mayor in the country uh
and now he's he has a real competition
with eric adams who is who has become
one of the top one percent of mayors
before he's even in office just for
merely being uh pro tech and
specifically crook pro crypto
yeah one one way to think about this is
it's a new type of a
concept
that anyone can adopt this concept right
so think about nfts like once people
understood or artists understood that
hey nfts are a thing they can make nfts
they can they can they can make make use
of them so many artists around the world
they basically started using nfts and
and i think city coins the concept is a
little bit like that for cities and
mayors so the technology is completely
open source is completely community
driven anyone can decide to use the
technology and i don't think they need
anyone's permission so i i think it will
the the adoption of the idea really
depends on how powerful the idea is how
much is it is it resonating with people
and how easy for
is it for them to get started right and
in this case like it's a completely
permissionless system completely
community driven so just like any artist
in the world would decide that hey you
know what i'm going to make an nft over
here similarly any any city government
on the planet could be like i like this
idea i'm going to use the open source
code and i'm going to start using it
john what questions you got yeah thank
you guys for joining us today this is an
innovative project you guys are working
on but can you talk about it from the
individual citizen level like how do
they participate in it what can they
expect to get like what is their role in
this situation
yeah so if you look at uh if you look at
a municipality as a proxy for citizens
like they're they represent the citizens
they should be enriching citizens um the
municipality gets 30 of all the mining
proceeds the the the crypto that's sent
into the mining function not um city
coins themselves so they're getting a
bunch of stacks so the city the city
it's the city's job to um make citizens
healthy happy and wealthy that is like
that is the goal of you know if you're
measuring state capacity that's those
are the three things i think you're
measuring and so uh city coins are just
another way for uh uh cities to benefit
their citizens if they want to
uh give it out like a crypto dividend
boom the city the the
citizens are getting uh getting rewarded
um citizens can also take it a step
further they can they can integrate you
know miami coin
into point of sale they can uh you know
local artists can uh mint with miami
coin are mixed with any city coin but
they can mint with miami coin you can
build applications uh that allow like
voting like dow like voting uh uh sort
of scenarios and there's one that's uh
getting announced at the end of the
month that miami is experimenting with
and this is like a demo app um but
essentially like you know you'd have
like coin holders be able to like vote
on specific uh agenda items that um that
the city proposes and is acceptable it
finds acceptable and finds any of them
acceptable um so uh and city coins are
uh really
accessible you know
you can buy one miami coin for like two
and a half cents right now and um you
know you're gonna you're gonna see
i think this decade essentially
everyone's gonna become in a stakeholder
or an investor
just out of accessibility and necessity
and i think you know you're going to
have you have people for all walks of
life uh having a shared interest in the
success of the city
so
yeah you can you can build by mine you
can you can you know trade you can um
can benefit from it
just like possibilities are kind of
endless i hope that answers your
question yeah and then to participate or
to buy for example do they set up a wall
to do that
yeah so you set up a web wallet at
hiro.so um
and just click to the sort of web wallet
and you can actually mine with that
wallet you can stack with that wallet to
earn uh to earn uh to earn more crypto
from your city coin um and
um
you can uh use that well to receive city
coins gotcha
awesome guys listen i appreciate you
guys taking that time to come on here uh
this is all moving uh incredibly fast
and i think that uh you know as i wrote
this morning i don't think anyone had on
their uh 2021 bingo card that uh u.s
city was going to pay people in bitcoin
uh and uh when i saw the cool valley
missouri thing that was uh interesting
right because it was like a private
contribution and then they were gonna
basically give a thousand dollars no one
could sell it for a pre uh specified
amount of time uh this has the potential
to have a very uh much more sustainable
thing it's not kind of a fundraising
that has to occur to be able to convert
dollars into into bitcoin or anything so
i think that there's uh still a ton of a
ton of things need to be figured out but
it seems to be uh to be working and uh
people are obviously very excited about
it so i appreciate it's coming on and uh
explaining it but also answering some
questions in terms of you know what the
risks are and how you guys think about
the future work that you have to uh to
continue to do
our pleasure thanks for having us on
awesome thank you so much sounds good
talk soon
see ya
the whole idea of earning bitcoin right
there's a lot of people who are going to
have questions about the mechanism of
which it it's done in and uh how it
works what is the
risks what are the um
concerns how sustainable it is et cetera
right right now i think they've done a
great job of kind of articulating how it
works uh but the idea that a city can
earn bitcoin right like imagine if you
take out uh for a second um this
specific mechanism and instead you just
say okay a city is going to uh ask
another city when they pay them pay us
in bitcoin right or whatever and then
turn around into dividend it
to citizens i think that's a wild
concept i wonder over time what their
participation rate will be i'm sure it
will vary by city right new york has
eight million people or whatever but
it's got to vary by city i i mean if you
think about
el salvador el salvador had uh what did
they end up with i think they have
somewhere around uh
50 percent
right maybe 35 to 50 percent of their
citizens that supposedly downloaded the
chivo wallet right because i know they
cross over 2 million 2 million is uh of
6.5 million citizens i'm assuming that
it's continued to go up so let's call it
35 maybe at a minimum maybe as they've
got as high as 50 percent
like that's pretty high rate for about
what september october you know two and
a half months yeah now they're paying 30
right so that that's a part of it um but
i think
if well if a city did the same thing you
know why would they not have the same
result right they said hey if you go get
a wallet you don't have to go get our
wallet just go get any wallet we're
gonna give you bitcoin
the other piece that nobody talks about
uh that i do think is worth um you know
kind of mentioning in the beginning is
and i said this uh in the letter at my
uh this morning uh trying my best to
articulate like i'm not an expert on
this stuff so i want to call that out
first but ubi uh universal basic income
i think there's a lot of folks myself
included who don't like the idea uh on
the surface of like let me go and create
money in some form or fashion uh that is
going to further depreciate the
purchasing power of the citizens that
hold that money let me create money and
then turn around and hand it to citizens
and i'm gonna do it over and over and
over and over again uh and it creates a
dependency on the government right as
part of your income now if you do the
same thing with bitcoin there's one
argument that's like well where is it
coming from you're not creating money
right the second thing is that you're
giving them sound money versus giving
them depreciating uh currency but
there is this element of like if you
just say okay cool we're gonna like
we're gonna give you uh
a tenth of a bitcoin every single month
right now that's you know 6 000-ish
dollars right in us dollar terms we're
gonna do that every single month how
many people will quit their jobs
right how many people would become
dependent on like like there's there's
some complexity here that uh i think
we've got to uh be aware of going into
it because you want to understand if
bitcoin is going to continue to get
adopted like what are the pros and the
cons so that you can kind of be eyes
wide open you know as a system what do
you think if they uh if they held it to
the end of the year and use that to
reduce your taxable income or your
taxable bill so that's where it gets
real interesting right is if all of a
sudden uh you know with this system
they're talking about it's uh uh
annualized it'd be 20 of their uh total
annual tax revenue yeah so if also they
said okay at the end of the year
everyone has to pay us 20 less taxes
miami don't have enough real estate for
all the people who try to move here
right yeah
i mean people were coming from all over
the world whereas on the extreme example
he's like can we 5x that and then
so again like you get into a world where
it's like do i think taxes are going
away no yeah right let's be very clear
what is probably more likely is hey
rather than us drop your tax rate now we
have more revenue and we can do other
things we can provide other programs
whatever so like let's um let's be uh
optimistic yet rational at the same time
um but but it's it's interesting like if
that's the other argument to ubi right
is like instead of giving them money or
or bitcoin or whatever it ends up being
uh and and almost people becoming
dependent on that through a ubi concept
you reduce the tax at the end of the
year that's one way that you could not
only attract people uh from a demand
standpoint but you could make sure
people aren't dependent on the
government correct
all right here we go before we bring
will clemente on we got a whole bunch of
stuff john you got a the next thing
we're giving away yep all right what are
we giving away next one two three smash
the like button we got a third product
we are giving away a heater for your
house for the winter
space here
a space here we have john face heater
john where did you come up with these i
was just on amazon this morning you're
just going on amazon looking around no
free ads this thing is sick so this is
this could be for your house this could
be for your office your garage you can
put it underneath your desk you can put
in your car or may not be safe but i
don't know if you can put in your car
but when you comment your twitter we
want to know where you're putting it
where you're using it so count it three
one two three smash the like button
we're giving out a space heater indoor
use 24 inch 1500 watt electric portable
heater ceramic heater with a thermostat
a remote a timer oscillation whoo big
boy oscillates i don't need this
personally i live in miami but i'm sure
some others could use it for the winner
all right
drop your twitter account drop your
instagram account we'll pick one person
when we get done talking to uh to will
and uh we'll go ahead and get you a
space heater if we can set an air fryer
to uh to japan we can send the space
heater anywhere in the world so go ahead
and uh drop your thank you i'm so cold
all right john's picking who the winner
is uh will i think we got you here
hey guys how's it going we're doing
great how are you
good good good
can't complain uh
just uh
oh well this is this is something to
talk about i got a bike recently so i've
been uh i've been biking around every
morning
are you on the uh are you on the roads
or trails
no i'm on the trail all right oh you got
like a like a trail bike like a mountain
like yeah yeah i got a mountain bike oh
that's awesome there's like a trail that
goes all around my my apartment so i'm
gonna get my cardio in
what do you say sean do you get a santa
cruz is that a model
yeah that's a brand nah it's a brand i
got i went to play it again sports gotta
use bike for like seven five bucks
play it again sports is a good spot
that's a great place to go all right so
will not only dropped out of college
this year not only had his rise as a
bitcoin analyst but he's got a mountain
bike now and he's he's rolling around
he's taking a semester off oh you take a
semester off that's right will's sold
the audi bought the bike wait really
no
i was like wait what you went from
selling bikes to buying one
all right let's get it we got a whole
bunch of stuff we got to get through
today so let's just start first with uh
the kind of price structure uh you went
ahead and you've got this uh uh this
tweet that or i'm sorry uh this chart
that shows kind of price movement over
the last couple of months what are you
seeing here
right so if you remember from last week
what we talked about was we were
expecting volatility i kind of said i
had no real strong opinion about where
price was headed in the short term
but
you know i was expecting some volatility
and that's when we were
right smack dab in the middle of these
the two bollinger bands
and so the squeeze is highlighted by
that yellow shaded area and i'm using
the wick high time frame indicator to
identify that
what we talked about last week was that
for the past three volatility squeezes
we've had we've initially gone in one
direction to grab liquidity from the
breakout traders and then gone in the
opposite direction and so once again
this this actually happened um again on
this on this fourth time on on wednesday
uh we broke out above the bollinger band
looked like we were having the squeeze
to the upside grabbed liquidity and then
reversed um and so yeah i mean i'm not
saying that i necessarily like called
this but it's just like we were prepared
for this and and what you know what we
had talked about last week was like we
were in the middle of the bands but to
to kind of check your you know check
your bias in terms of like you know it
it it did look like it was breaking to
the upside but you know if we if you
have been paying attention to what we
mentioned in the newsletter last week
then you wouldn't have you know just
been
you know fully bullish like you would
you would have been aware that there's
potential that we would have this
reversal which we end up doing so now
we've had four of those in a row uh
where we've broken out grab liquidity
and reverse
as far as like price structure um these
are just levels that i've i've had in
here for like weeks now um you know i
think as long as we're above this kind
of green this green zone which was that
point of breakdown from earlier this
year um i remain bullish i mean i'm not
saying that this will happen but i think
we could correct as low as like 51 to
53k and still have
still maintain like bullish market
structure i think if that happened you
would see some some you know sideways
consolidation but i think as long as we
were maintaining above that level just
from like a pure price structure
standpoint um you know i'm not like
macro bearish got it okay and then you
have this piece here where essentially
once we saw that uh break all the way up
to 69 000 which is of course like
bitcoin hitting 69 thousand dollars is
uh is almost like the mean we bet we
didn't hit 69 420 that would have been
even better dude the memes write
themselves like of course 69 000 is the
bitcoin all-time high uh we got a large
influx of open interest so what are you
seeing here with this futures open
interest perpetual on the exchanges
right so as we broke all-time highs you
just saw a real big influx of open
interest basically people trying to buy
that breakout as as we mentioned a
second ago
especially on binance you saw a real
high
increase in
open interest particularly um the coin
margin contracts or crypto margin
contracts so we've talked about this
before um when you're margining a
futures contract with crypto versus
stable coins or usd um you have more
convexity to the downside which just a
fancy term for saying you know as the
trade goes against you you're long
you're basically longing your longs
right you're longing bitcoin with
bitcoin um let's say you know the trade
starts to go against you well not only
is your p l going down your profit and
loss going down or the you know the
profit of the trade is going down but
your collateral or how how
collateralized you are is is decreasing
in tandem with that um and so that can
create these these washouts and so yeah
we had a large uh increase in
uh open interest as well as um funding
was rising a bit
and then you pair that with you know we
had like the cpi data as well as
evergrand news and then we also had a
couple uh major exchanges that went down
including ftx which from my
understanding that's like the first time
ftx has gone down during any kind of
like significant uh market move usually
ftx has always been the one exchange
that hasn't gone down
and so i mean i don't think you can
really like pinpoint price action at
least one specific thing but like those
factors kind of uh you know gave the
perfect recipe for a flesh out
got it now sopra this is the entity
adjusted sopra uh which i feel like you
and i sopra we're uh we're on a journey
together here but what's going on with
sopra
all right so sober is our spent output
profit ratio so we're looking at um when
a coin was last moved and and when it's
being moved so okay let me say this
we're looking at all the coins that are
trading on a given day so you know
it's you the coins that are being spent
today you're looking at the profit and
loss that those coins that are being
spent today hold so if a coin was you
know bought at
50k it's now being moved at 60k well
that coin's realizing ten thousand
dollars of profit if a coin was bought
you know at the pico top at 69k
and then now it's sold down here at 63k
well it's realizing six thousand dollars
losses so you're only looking at the
coins that are being spent on on each
given trading day and then you run the
ratio between the profit and loss and
you get sober which is spent i'll put
profit ratio
one is kind of that threshold where you
know if you divide one by one it's
neutral right so if the profit and loss
is balancing each other out then you're
at one
above that the market's trading in a
state of profit below it's trading in a
net state of loss
and so what you want to see in bearish
trend or well in bullish trends is
coming back down and bouncing off that
one threshold on any kind of major
correction and bearish trends what
you're looking for is a failed retest
from the underside of one um and so what
you'll see is
uh you can't see this on the chart but
we bounced off uh one in in september of
last year we had a continued uptrend in
the ratio
as you can see we had i didn't i didn't
label this actually but you can see this
bearish divergence where the oscillator
was making lower highs as price was
making higher highs so that was kind of
an early warning sign we had this
reversal broke down below one
and that's what i have marked as that
bearish break so at that point you know
you can have a bearish bias but you
don't quite have absolute confirmation
yet
coming back down you know
that that initial failed break above
that range we were in over summer we had
that failed retest from the underside of
of one and that was confirmation that we
were in uh kind of a broader bullish
trend um got a second uh confirmation of
you know the underside test of one and
then very shortly after we actually got
a bullish break above one um and so from
there then you you know you have bullish
bias generally towards the market but we
are once again waiting for that
confirmation uh we came back down and
retested 40k
about a month ago at the end of
september and that's when we got that
bullish confirmation now we're kind of
hovering uh you know a bit above one um
you know i would love to come down and
retest um you know on some kind of
correction and hit that one threshold
but when you go back to last year i mean
after we had that retest after september
uh we had like a 25 correction right
before the major uh phase of the bull
run at the end of last year and we never
came back down and retested one again we
just continued an uptrend so
what i'm looking for is
if we have a price correction to come
back down and re-test one in general
though i'm expecting this probably just
to trend higher and you know as we get
further into the bull run i would be
looking for another bearish divergence
as as you can see we had on the
left-hand side of the chart um you know
when we were in like april uh march
april kind of time frame
when we look at this utxo realized price
distribution uh you've got it squared
off and you said 18.36 percent of the
supply why are you calling that out and
explain what this chart's showing us
sure so this is realized price
distribution so we talk about realized
price which is uh the capitalization of
bitcoin based off the last time coins
are moved so you know with this in mind
what this is showing is
if a coin is last moved at 1 000 no it's
in the it's in the 1000
bar volume if it's then moved once again
at 20k well now it's pulled out of the
1k bar and moved into the 20k bar so
that's where the realized aspect is
coming from you're so you're essentially
looking at where uh
where each denominated at each
denominated uh price level how much of
supply has last moved there
and so as you can see
above 50 i forget the exact number
because it changes as supply increases
of what exactly the price level is that
the 1 trillion market cap threshold is
but it's above 53k so i just cut it off
at 54k
but roughly 18.3 percent 18.36 percent
of bitcoin's money supply has moved
above that one trillion dollar uh
threshold and so to me that's showing
that there's confirmation from the
market uh well from marked participants
you know that this you know asset class
is here to stay um and that you know
bitcoin is is establishing itself as
like a as a maturing macro asset i think
you know that that one trillion uh that
one trillion threshold is kind of a line
in the sand as you can see that's kind
of where this cluster that we're
currently in starts
got it and when you look at this price
distribution uh that cluster what are
you looking to see happen over like say
the remainder of the bull market like
what is your expectation there
um i mean the way i just see it is like
by definition you're showing where a lot
of mark participants or capital inflows
have come in so ideally like these zones
of volume are kind of uh support or
resistance levels because they're
they're levels where market participants
have interacted heavily with so if
you're coming up from the underside to a
large you know cluster of of uh you know
realized price distribution and saying
you're probably going to face some
resistance some people that are taking
profits
and then conversely if you know for
correcting then you know i look for some
of these uh some of these zones as like
you know support levels um on on the you
know on a move down so
that's kind of the way i see it um but
yeah i mean this will definitely change
over time because you know you'll have
coins that are um you know
in whatever 40 50 you know and those in
those price levels that are gonna move
once we go higher so you know this is
this is just something to to watch in
terms of like identifying where a lot of
this investor behavior is going on
got it and so when we look at this uh
new chart that you have the uh i
appreciate in the newsletter that you uh
published this morning you said next we
take a look at a new variant of illiquid
supply that i created yesterday like you
are moving so fast to create some of
this stuff and continue to analyze it
what are you showing here in this new
illiquid supply shock uh kind of this
new variation of
it sure so usually we look at a liquid
supply shock ratio which i created with
willy woo over the summer
what that basically is doing is it's
comparing the liquid guys which are
essentially the strong hands so they
take in
and don't spend at least 75 percent of
those of the coins they take in so for
every four coins they take in they hold
at least three uh the liquid guys take
in and spend 50 50 and then the highly
liquid guys spend over 75 percent of the
coins they take in so for every four
coins they take and they only hold one
and so you run the ratio of the liquid
aka the strong hands to the weak hands
which are the highly and and
highly liquid and liquid guys
and that's what the liquid supply shock
ratio is
but i just was tinkering around with it
and like took it a step further by
applying an rsi to it um and you can
apply different time frames i just
thought this one was the clearest the
two month or 60 day version of it you
could look at it like the 30 day version
or whatever um but what i'm what i'm
just trying to point out here is similar
to uh what we talked about in soper with
the bearish divergence and also you'll
see in the chart after this another
bearish divergence to non-chain
um what you're looking for here is
seeing that
the rsi which is essentially measuring
the momentum so in this case you're
looking at the momentum of a liquid
supply shock so you're looking at the
momentum of the supply dynamics right so
you know if if you have a bearish
divergence which is when the oscillator
is making lower highs then showing the
the amount of supply or the strength of
the supply shock is getting weaker
meanwhile you know price is making
higher highs so you can see that happen
in 2017 um once we broke that down trend
in 2019 at the bottom of 2019 then i
kind of marked the bottom of the bear
market we had a continued uptrend in the
ratio um and then as you can see kind of
at like the the beginning of this year
actually you could you could say it
started as as we broke all-time highs in
december at the end of last year we
began this this bearish divergence
between the oscillator
and price once we broke below that the
green line i have which is this which is
you know showing the uptrend in the
metric once we broke below that
then we had that may capitulation event
so showing that the trend of supply
getting locked up uh broke um and then
since then we've we've broken back above
that downtrend uh which is like you know
a bullish break above very similar to
what we just talked about it you know at
the beginning of 2019 when we broke that
down trend so uh you know we're in we're
in bullish territory now um we broke
that at the end of september um after we
retested 40k
and so you know what i'm looking for
moving forward and like
i posted this yesterday and like
you know maybe maybe it's a big
miscommunication on my end but um you
know it seems like some people kind of
miss nuance in the sense of like
i wasn't saying that this this is
bearish i'm just saying like what i'm
looking for moving forward so like you
know we've we've been um you know
i kind of got caught off guard by the
move in may and then over summer i
really kind of grinded out my
understanding of all this stuff because
you know i i kind of you know i was kind
of pissed that you know i missed the
whole move and then i really got like
dove deep and on chain created a lot of
these new metrics and like really took
it seriously uh and so now you know with
that being with that in mind like i'm
looking for moving forward you know what
are some of them trying to stay
objective as possible and look for you
know what are the things moving forward
that we we can identify that are showing
that the market's starting to get
overheated or when we should start
becoming cautious and with this specific
metric what i'm looking for is another
bearish divergence as we had in 2017
and also earlier this year so um you
know we're in bullish territory for the
metric now um and as you can see you
know it takes a couple touches of in you
know on that on that downtrend once we
begin the bearish divergence before it
actually plays out but you know after we
have two three touches per se you know
i'll you know probably start to become
pretty cautious especially paired with
um some other metrics but that's you
know that's what i'm looking for
specifically with this metric moving
forward
got it and then checkmate has this uh
market realized gradient uh i'm
unfamiliar with this so how do you
describe this you put a little bit in
the newsletter in terms of the actual
language that's used to uh to describe
it but like
how do you think about this in a way
that people can use it
yeah so this this is a great metric uh
created by czech maiden um checkmate was
uh checkmate's been doing on chain since
like 2018 and checkmate was actually
bearish
earlier this year mostly because of this
metric
and so what essentially you're looking
at here is
the rate of change between realized cap
and price and so we've talked about
realize cap i'm not going to explain it
because i feel like we talked about it
every time i talked about two minutes
ago but um you're looking at the rate of
change so the amount of new capital
inflows relative to the speculative bid
on price um and so you know as long as
as long as realize cap is increasing
along with the rate of change of price
then you know it's fine we're in an
uptrend and that's that's what you're
seeing right now um but earlier this
year you had uh the rate of change of
realized price was going down as price
was increasing so you had this bearish
divergence between um the the realized
gradient and price um and so that's
that's what i'm looking for moving
forward as we get you know
higher over the coming months which i'm
expecting um you know i'm looking for
this oscillator to start making these
these lower highs um you know
essentially you're just looking at like
the the the delta which just means like
the difference between the rate of
change of of realized cap or new capital
inflows and the speculative bid that
market participants are bidding up the
market
got it and then when you start to look
at uh this on-chain cost basis i think
we talked about this uh maybe last week
but there there's definitely been kind
of a reversal of the previous trend so
describe this one
yes so dylan had this good idea about a
month ago or so to compare the
short-term holder and long-term holder
realized price
and if you can't tell like realize price
is one of the most important metrics in
on in on-chain analysis to understand
but specifically by comparing the
short-term and long-term holder realized
price you can get some interesting
signals so another way to think of
realized price is um a you can think of
it as for someone who's like a more
technical trader a v-op which is a
volume weighted average price
or you could just think of it as the
cost basis of investors
and so
by looking at the short and long term
holders what what you see is that when
short term holder cost basis goes below
the long term holder cost basis or
realized price that's generally a good
time to to start buying heavily um and
and that's highlighted by that you know
you'll see that that green line at the
bottom
what that's basically showing is like
all the the short term holder or the
speculators um you know that were that
were you know
likely in the in the previous bull run
or or they had kind of bought on the way
down you know thinking that it was just
like a another by the dip opportunity or
whatever um they kind of capitulate you
know when the market seems like it's
never going to stop going down right
because i mean
you know newbies usually buy when they
think the market isn't going to ever
stop going up and they sell when they
think the market isn't going to stop
going down which is the complete
opposite of what you should be doing but
nonetheless um you know this is just
showing that you know there's the
short-term guys completely leave during
the bear market and we that's also
reflected by like short-term holder
supply and like hotter waves
but they leave in the bear market and
then conversely
we can use this to kind of identify when
the market's getting overheated in the
bull market uh when short-term holder
realized price kind of way you know
overshoots uh long term hold at realize
price so just showing that you know the
the short term guys are dominating the
market and and they're basically you
know buying the buying uh the long term
holders guys bags and there's a lot of
exuberance and new market entrance in
the market so
got it and then we got a red print on
the long-term holder net position change
um
is this bullish or bearish i guess is my
first question and then like what why do
you see
uh why do you think we're seeing this
like can you explain like like what's
driving it
yeah um yeah i posted this one this
morning and um
there's definitely some confusion as to
like what this exactly means
[Laughter]
but what we're looking at here is the
30-day change of long-term holder supply
so we're looking at for example you know
what was long-term holder supply on
october 12th and then we're comparing it
to today and we take the net change
between the two um and so what we've
talked about for the for the past two
week well let's back it up over summer
we started this re-accumulation phase
and we saw that the long-term guys were
starting to lock up supply ver via the
liquid supply and also just the
long-term holder supply metric of the
glass node
and so what we talked about is that
we're looking to reach this peak hotter
level which we've reached i mean
honestly faster than
i thought we would we we reached an
all-time high in the long term holder
supply shock ratio and since then we
started to see old coins being spent and
this is something that we've talked
about you know
this this is natural bull market
behavior what you see in these natural
dynamics between mark participants is
that the long-term guys buy weakness
they set the floor in the bear market
and then once the kind of reflexivity of
a full-blown bitcoin bull market or
momentum of a full-blown bitcoin uh bull
market takes off then you have the
short-term guys or new market entrants
that come in and buy the long-term the
long-term guys bags the whole way up
um and so you know
we peeked out well like i said we peeked
out reach an all-time high in the spy
shock ratio
now we're starting to see those those
long-term holders distribute uh we can
see this via long-term holder supply
long-term holder net position change um
you know average spent output life span
spent volume age bands coin dates
destroyed dormancy um all these
different metrics uh that are just
showing that you're you're starting to
see these long-term guys um sell off and
that's not that doesn't mean that the
bull market is over that's just like i
said natural bull market dynamics
and as you can see when when the
long-term guys actually initiated uh or
started to to sell uh previously uh you
know that was at actually kind of
coincidentally at the end of october of
last year you know that was at the very
beginning of the bull run and and you
know we always talk about how these guys
don't perfectly time the tops and
bottoms like they don't perfectly buy
the pico bottom of the of the bear
market and they don't perfectly time the
the pico top of of uh the bulls they
kind of you know scale into the bear and
scale out in the bowl
and so you're just starting to see them
scale out and that you know that
this is this is a bullish chart over the
coming months
but you know once once we once we start
to see real heavy selling like as you
can see like in january the
beginning of this year um then you know
you can start
start to become cautious and then when
we flip green that's actually generally
kind of a a bearish signal because
that's showing that the long-term guys
you know have started buying back again
and that's like naturally what what uh
bear market behavior uh looks like so um
you know this isn't something to be like
entirely concerned about at all it's
just like you know just keep an eye on
this over the next couple you know next
couple months and this is kind of the
start of the end but that you know it
doesn't mean to say that we don't have a
long way to go because these guys don't
you know they've just started scaling
out and they definitely don't perfectly
time the top so yeah i tend to think
that that's right based on the the data
that we have from previous uh kind of
upward movements uh we've got supply
shock ratios what uh what what are you
seeing here same kind of reversal right
there at the bottom
right yeah i mean this is just another
visual to show the same thing um so this
is like the complete zoomed out version
though so green is long-term holder
supply uh and purple or fuchsia whatever
you want to call that color that's the
short-term holder supply and so you i'm
just
threw this in there to show that dynamic
um you know you see in 2013
the long-term guys were buying up until
the main phase of that that first leg up
they scaled out during that and then
they re-bought during that kind of mini
bear phase between the two 2013 double
pumps and then they sold again um into
that rally while the short-term guys
bought their bags the whole way up
long-term guys started scaling in
through the bear market short-term guys
left at the you know very pico bottom of
of short-term holder supply that's when
the market starts to reverse because all
the short-term speculators are
completely gone um and you know the
people that are buying down there have
strong hands you know because they're
buying when the market looks completely
dead and these are guys with like
long-term conviction so they kind of set
that floor
as we head back into the the main phase
of the bowl then you start to see the
long-term guys scale out again
short-term guys buy their bags up and so
you see this pattern right um throughout
all bitcoin's history and as you can see
we're just starting to reverse the
short-term holder supply but you know
another way to look at it is the metric
that
i've been throwing in for a few weeks
just the long-term holder supply shock
ratio where we kind of reached that
that's comparing the long-term and the
short-term guys through a simple ratio
and so through that you're basically
adjusting adjusting this for supply um
and and because you know by definition
like long-term holder supply is going to
trend up you know as there's more supply
and circulation so running the ratio
between short long-term guys kind of
alleviates that like uh
you know
the disadvantage that that you have by
by not like adjusting it for supply but
yeah you're starting to see that reverse
and this is just another way to show
what what we just looked at
but like this is just the zoomed out
version essentially got it when we look
at transaction fees i remember during
the summer one of the things that you
had said was hey you know i got to see
transactions pick up uh because that
would be like my biggest bearish
argument against bitcoin right now with
this is transaction fees uh what are you
seeing here looks like it's ticking up a
little bit
um yeah i mean going back i think i
probably would adjust what i said in the
sense of like
doesn't necessarily mean that uh
the the market itself is bearish because
like low low you know
low demand or or low activity could also
just mean like all the speculators are
gone and it's really just like the smart
money that's left in the market and like
if i could have changed the way or what
i was saying it's just more of like
bull market you know
bull market behavior now you know
throughout bitcoin's history has has
included you know increasing uh network
activity and so we are starting to see
it pick up in that i mean very slight
you see in the bottom right it's very
slight compared to you know what we've
seen in 2017 and
at the end of last year leading into the
beginning of this year but i'm watching
to see if we get that continued uptrend
um you know it looks like once we kind
of broke that up trend previously uh
that's that's you know when when the
market started to reverse as well as
like i think you can also kind of use
this as a as kind of a topping signal
where you have that you know huge
blow-off spike and that kind of means
that there's like you know exuberance
and mania and like a lot of you know new
speculators in the market and so the
market's getting a little frothy so um
yeah i'm looking for you know a
sustained uptrend in fees because i
think fees are like a good way to kind
of proxy like block space demand
as well as like some kind of major you
know spike um you know in the in the
months coming ahead
got it and then we've got the exchange
net position change uh that's in the red
it has been for a while now uh kind of
same thing continuation of what we
previously saw
right right i mean
yeah like we're seeing outflows in the
short term um but also what i just
wanted to show here with the full zoomed
out version is like after march of 2020
i don't want to use the word paradigm
new paradigm but like
we've kind of seen this this trend
change and market you know participants
behavior where aside from like
at the end of 2016 leading into 2017
where you saw some pretty heavy like
consistent outflows and there's no
comparable time in bitcoin's market
history to the last year so where we've
just seen sustained outflows um as well
as before the major uh you know down
down draw that we had over the summer
we had the the highest day of daily uh
inflows to finance so that's like
another you know you know if we start to
see real uh large inflows to exchanges
you know day after day then you know
it's probably time to to be a bit wary
but for now we're still in kind of this
sustained period of outflows and zooming
out after march it seems like we're kind
of in this uh you know
new trend in behavior from from market
participants i mean i think you could
partially just attribute that to like
institutions being in the market driven
by the whole inflation hedge narrative
etc
and you know they're looking to take
custody of their btc in general
got it and then when you think about
this uh very last chart you have around
miners uh it looks like um you know
we've got everything in here from uh uh
where the chinese minor migration or the
chinese mining band occurred all the way
back to it coming back online pretty
aggressively which looks pretty bullish
is that your general read
yeah um you know i think i think um
like hash is definitely correlated to
what the value of the bitcoin network is
because the more hash there is on the
network than the more secure the network
is right
and so you know seeing hash come back
online is is great in that sense and
then also just for the decentralization
of bitcoin um you know mining was was
really heavily concentrated in china and
so that was one of the biggest you know
flood narratives that that you know
bitcoin bit excuse me uh that bitcoin
bears would would throw at us right and
they'd say well all the all the miners
are in china and so it's it was pretty
funny honestly over summer that you know
you had all these people that use that
as kind of their their one of their main
like
bearish uh narratives around bitcoin or
arguments against bitcoin and then you
start to see hash leaving china and
going across the world and and
decentralizing itself across the world
and then they're saying you know oh well
all the all the you know hash came off
the network so you know it's just like
it's completely contradicting yourself
but um but yeah i mean just seeing hash
come back online is is a great sign
because it just shows the resilience of
the bitcoin network right um you know it
doesn't matter what centralized entity
you know
bans bitcoin i mean bitcoin hash is
going to find a new home somewhere else
and and the network is doesn't have any
centralized uh point of failure so i
mean yeah i mean it kind of sucked we
had you know hash drawdown and some a
bit of a bit of selling for miners over
the summer but you know the network uh
has come back out even stronger from
that um and so you know bitcoin has a
lot of these events where it's kind of
like
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
type deal and for long-term investors
you know this was a real bullish event
in my mind
and a reflection of that hash coming
back online aggressively as you can see
in difficulty in the purple or blue line
whatever you want to call that
we've had eight consecutive positive
difficulty adjustments so it's just
another reflection of
how aggressive hashes come back online
got it joe john what questions do you
guys have it will so we looked at the
chart earlier about long-term holders
selling into strength um and it looks
like it has just started
is there any historical evidence of how
we should think about this like how long
it can go what metrics you should be
looking at et cetera
um
yeah let me can i screen share
probably i don't think so okay um if
you're able to
go into i think is the newsletter two
weeks ago
what you'll see is and i'll like talk
through it if you're not able to get it
up um
what you see is that i have the the
long-term molar supply shock ratio
basically plotted out and kind of like
this descending wedge
if you will and so whenever we tag the
upper trend line of that um and for
anybody listening and and like if you're
by chance not able to get it up look at
uh week 12 newsletter and then scroll
down it's like the the sixth or seventh
chart in the in the newsletter
when we tag the upper trend line of that
that's usually where we we've kind of uh
peaked out and because that's showing
that
you have a large amount of supply that's
moving to short-term holders
and then conversely when we tag the
bottom of that trend line
those have actually been really really
good uh bottom signals so it's shown the
bottom
at the end of 2015
as well as at the bottom of 2018 and
then also during the covet crash we came
back down and tagged the bottom of that
trend line
we hit the bottom of that trend line
about a month ago and so now i'm looking
to reverse back to the upper part of the
trend line in this kind of descending
wedge um and so once we kind of get up
and you know at least in the upper half
of the wedge you know that's when i'll
start to start to kind of look to be
cautious just based off of the behavior
of long-term holders um that's that's
that's you know probably the the best
visual to get like a clear signal on
like you know when when to become
cautious or or you know optimistic about
the market gotcha and i i trust you will
educate us on that when it gets closer
yeah
keep an eye on it all right john what
you got yo what's up will um hey man so
what was your takeaway so what did the
on-chain metrics say about this week's
volatility we saw go bitcoin go as high
as 69 69 000 and then as low as 63 000
was that like i probably wasn't expected
and we know it's volatile but what was
your takeaway from all that
yeah i mean i think in the i think in
the short term when you have kind of
these whipsaw moves um a lot of that is
is more so driven by the derivative
stuff
um you know we do insane amounts of uh
volume and you know there's insane
amounts of liquidity in the in the
perpetual futures market
and so in the short term you know when
those traders get offsides you have
these kind of uh you know flush outs or
reversals and so that happens often
that's that's part of why bitcoin's so
volatile i think you know in the past
like in like the bitmex glory days
bitcoin and stream is just like a free
walk trying to liquidate the most
traders uh i still think we have that to
an extent um
and so like that you know i think that
drives a lot of the short-term
volatility but you know when you're
trying to just zoom out and like you
know you don't care about the day-to-day
fluctuations that's where on-chain more
so comes into play um i mean you did see
you did see like some increased spending
as we've talked about from these
long-term guys um as well as you know
some slight like exchange outflows
before the event but uh more than it
more than anything i think a lot of
these short-term moves are just driven
by the derivatives thanks for that
well if you zoom all the way out we are
now into q4 of 2021. what's your general
read we're you know hitting all-time
highs is this kind of what you would
have expected in the beginning of the
year or into the spring like q4 of uh
the year after a halving we're hitting
all-time highs
yeah i mean i think i know a lot more
about the market than i do like
than i did earlier this year like i kind
of look back on myself and cringe a
little bit um but i mean yeah like we've
been talking about how we've kind of
been expecting higher prices into the
end of the year um i think some of these
on chain like supply specific dynamics
um that we're seeing and as well as like
like you know coin days destroyed and
stuff um some of those things kind of
point to
maybe this extending out into the first
few months of next year
um
you know i don't i don't necessarily
look for for timing and we've talked
about this before like i don't look for
timing as to okay the market's going to
end the cycle is going to end in
december because that's when it's
historically ended i'm just looking for
these behaviors so
um
you know i know it's this time time
again but it's like i don't have
specific time or price targets it's more
so like
what are the behaviors that have
you know previously resembled exuberance
or greed in the market and once we see
those i don't know if that happens next
month you know that could all of a
sudden happen within a matter of weeks
or you know it might take several months
for us to get to that point but
historically in terms of how long it's
taken for these dynamics to kind of play
out i mean i think i think there's a
reasonable argument to be made that we
kind of extend out a few months into
next year
but yeah i mean my my conservative kind
of price target for the end of the year
was always i said all-time highs to
about 75k
um and i you know i still think that's
in the cards um but i mean as far as the
absolute like
pico top i mean we'll have to just you
know keep monitoring these behaviors to
know
for forever what what are we doing on a
follower account uh
how are we looking on a follower count
uh
i don't know uh let me see well because
i did i did the video with um
with willy woo and plan b and i think
that boosted me up a little bit oh i'm
at 392. oh bro you got this come on i
said 500k i've been saying 500k let's go
will's out of my distance now he was
like you know he came by me in the car
and passed and now he's in a different
state
yeah he waved and he said i'll see you
later
listen man i appreciate you coming on
here every week i know people are
learning i get dms all the time people
say listen i'm really learning a lot so
thank you guys for spending the time to
do this if you are not following will at
this point uh you must be new here which
is good we like new people that's fine
uh but highly suggest you go follow will
on on twitter and then also will i think
i saw you in the youtube uh comments
this week when dylan came on you were uh
you're in there dropping all kinds of
heat and asking me to ask him what was
the thing on top of his block clock
we'll get in the cube which yeah you got
a cube
no no cubes for me yeah where i i had to
i had to get the bike instead but
[Laughter]
probably a better person pretty good uh
purchase i think all right man
you know what you know i had to you know
had to bust dylan's balls a little bit
yeah listen he appreciated it he i mean
he came on and and uh the first thing i
said to him was he was all kind of
dressed up and everything had his chain
hanging and every and i said hey you
look you look uh spiffy there he goes
yeah you know i gotta have to drip
i was like all right i appreciate them
uh but thank you so much for uh for
coming on and uh we'll do it again next
week i think everyone is uh we're we're
all waiting what is will going to drop
next either what metric is he going to
create or or is he going to tell us
something's going to happen before it
happens so keep up the good work and uh
you know this weekend don't do anything
that my brothers and i would do
thanks guys and you know i appreciate
you like you know continuing to push the
the on-chain stuff
you know outside of just like doing
these interviews but as well like on
twitter and stuff you know i think uh
the further we we can push this
information out to new people then it's
just you know it's a it's a additive
thing where you know other people come
up with metrics you create something
based off of their stuff and you know we
can kind of it's it's still so early in
terms of uh like you know the the the
metrics we have and like the information
and data we have that you know i think
it it you know it's it's a it's a
win-win for everybody and and we can
kind of all win together at least at
least for now maybe like years down the
road the alpha will get uh we'll get uh
you know
squeezed out a little bit as more people
take on a chance seriously but
no no no we're all in this together my
friend joe john you guys got anything
left nah man have a good weekend will
appreciate you joining us thanks buddy
all right guys see you take it easy see
ya
what else
giveaway kid to wizard wizard wizard
yeah legend
john played against sports all the time
hey the bike he he uh he's biking around
you see will on a bike in uh at ecu you
probably listen to a podcast trying to
get smarter yeah all right so i got a
winner for the space eater giveaway uh
yeah no josh i wasn't gonna forget about
the spacey
who's the winner benny
bronov
i think it is
i never thought on this show i'd say
benny you win a space heater
congratulations he's putting it in his
bedroom it's cold
so okay all right
on the count of three one two three hit
the like button do we got one more
physical product john no we're doing the
podcast
joe's show joe show hold on uh excuse me
excuse me i would just like to make this
a uh caveat this clarification this is
my giveaway
i walked into the office today and i was
sitting there about to do work and then
joe hit me with uh by the way i'm doing
a giveaway today
does that mean you're funding it he goes
yeah okay he thinks i'm gonna ask him to
fund my idea i said okay hold on i said
okay big dog no problem
i said what is the giveaway and then
when you guys hear this you'll hear what
a genius idea it is well let's clarify
something real quick these are great
ideas i robot uh we're cleaning people's
houses
all that the crock pots whatever feeding
people i'm giving away bitcoin which is
what people came here for
that's the fact so what you have to do
what what do we think uh yeah
everyone calm down i will be giving away
100 of bitcoin to three separate people
three separate people
to enter
you have to go to the podcast the joe
pomp show
apple podcast spotify
etc you have to subscribe you have to
subscribe to the podcast screenshot it
and tweet it at me for evidence i want
proof
three people i'll pick on monday i'll dm
you at least get a hundred dollars of
bitcoin if you want cash sure but
let's give bitcoin away hold on let's
rewind just
first of all joe is not an expert
giveaway giver no no
hold on hold on i don't need to be an
expert i'm giving away bitcoin that says
everything i mean
this is a bitching moment from from uh
uh expert gives away
just sit down over there all right to a
young grasshopper you guys don't know
how to do giveaways like well the first
rule of giveaways is that when someone
said a hundred's weak sauce no no he's
giving away 300.
hold on a second you got a good shot
hold on hold on there's chaos on the
show everyone chill out for a second the
first thing and the most important thing
is that for the giveaway the best thing
that joe could do is drop the link to
the podcast which i have been doing the
entire time has been talking in the chat
so go to the chat you can click the link
it's an expert it's it's just a fast
highway right to it all you got to do is
you subscribe and screenshot it
once you do that then you can tweet it
at joe make sure you tweet at him and
tell him that you want the bitcoin now
he's also giving away what you say 300.
three people we should get 100.
three people each of them get a hundred
dollars you screenshot that you
subscribed and you tweet it at me are
those links in the chat
those are the terms and conditions there
are no lawyers involved no fine print
nothing you send it to me i'm gonna pick
three people each of you is gonna get a
hundred dollars in bitcoin not each
person three people
yeah yeah
three people one hundred dollars in
bitcoin one hundred dollars in bitcoin
one hundred dollars and you subscribe to
the podcast to subscribe to the podcast
screenshot it and send it to me on tw
twitter tweet it at me and we'll go
bonus if you subscribe on youtube apple
and spotify well okay so hold on so now
if you screenshot me three pictures you
might just be picked on the spot
i don't know if you're on youtube now
i'm two steps ahead of you because not
only have i dropped the itunes
uh link now i've also dropped the uh
spotify link as well so let's go let's
speed it up here i love the people that
say like oh it's available wherever you
listen to anything it's it's on there
joe's got all the platforms so go there
you get a chance to 100 bitcoin all
right anything else that you got going
on with your giveaways expert boy
no i appreciate all y'all watching
should we tell everyone what you've been
doing this whole show
i got a blanket
it's cold in here
that's the work from home blanket yeah
that's the worst home blanket
unless you were willing to say that
that's the yak blanket i said yeah
joe been sitting here the whole time
with a blanket like he needs a space
heater
i uh uh
i i was cold um
so i got a blanket
pretty simple
all right
a hundred dollars three people joe
oh yeah my my twitter someone's asking
is at joe pompeo
you guys think anyone was asking well no
someone said what's your twitter you
gotta tweet it at me tweet me the
screenshot and i'm gonna pick some
people look i think this is hey i i am
biased here but i think this is a pretty
good giveaway you go subscribe there
aren't going to be a thousand people
entered usually there's 3 000 comments
every time we do one your chances are
here so uh you should participate
i appreciate all of you tuning in to the
best business show please make sure that
you go ahead you like the video also
make sure you subscribe to the channel
yeah there we go i got lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots look at that nice
a nice crisp 321 thousand followers
i gotta update my photo i'm looking like
a chump in that photo
let me just take this yeah let me get a
new photo yeah there you go all right we
got that thank you all for watching very
much i hope everyone has a wonderful
friday pay off your credit cards pay off
your credit cards
pomp see you guys on monday
[Music]
you